when the lights went up in theaters
showing the batman there was still one
more riddle left for moviegoers to solve
just what exactly happens if you go to
the website the riddler uses in the film
watch to the end of the video to find
out oh and it should go without saying
but major spoilers ahead now if you've
already seen the batman directed by matt
reeves then you know there's a lot to
unpack following robert pattinson as the
caped crusader the movie is set in a
dark gotham brought into chaos by a
killer called the riddler played by paul
dano thanks to the heroic efforts of
batman catwoman and lieutenant jim
gordon the riddler's plan is stopped
before he can completely destroy the
city and its citizens but even though
the good guys win in the end the batman
still hints at there possibly being more
to come with riddler in the future
throughout the film as our heroes
attempt to track down the riddler the
villain leaves puzzles for batman to
solve one riddle in particular leads him
to a website with the url of
ratalata.com
this connects him with the riddler live
through a simple coded chat through
which bruce digs for any answers he can
get out of the criminal while the
website is a secret tool for riddler in
the batman warner brothers decided to
actually create the website in real life
so what happens when you head there the
hell are you supposed to be
keeping in line with the website's
function in the batman ratalata.com
brings you into a conversation with a
chatbot made to mimic the riddler
character from the movie he offers you
the chance to play a game and solve
three riddles and if you get them all
correct you will unlock the truth fair
warning though the solutions to these
riddles aren't easy and we aren't all
experts at riddles like batman appears
to be even so in the batman bruce has
some help from oswald cobblepot aka the
penguin and lieutenant gordon but in
this case you're on your own adding to
the feeling that you're talking to the
real riddler a man who's an expert at
codes and technology the website is well
aware of how much time you take between
guesses whether or not you go to another
tab or window to try to look up the
answers or even if you close the window
entirely and return later to try again
if you think you're smart enough to
conquer these three riddles and claim
the prize you can head to the website
and see what you unlock who are you
under there before the movie's release
the site featured riddles that would
unlock promotional material like police
sketches of batman from the gotham city
police department but now that the movie
has debuted the reward for providing the
right answers has changed how am i part
of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were if you manage to get
all three riddles correct and there are
only three riddles in total then you can
unlock a secret image of the wayne
family from before bruce's parents death
the photo shows thomas wayne martha
wayne and a young bruce played by luke
roberts stella stalker and oscar novak
respectively relaxing on the floor in
the lavishly appointed living room of
wayne manor in the film the riddler's
personal connection to the wayne family
plays a major part in his plan so it
makes sense that one of the secrets the
riddler reveals is connected to this
part of bruce's past the caption
underneath the photo describes the
images having been taken during thomas
wayne's mayoral campaign while also
mentioning the renewal corporation the
latter of which has plenty of
significance in the plot of the batman
meanwhile the image file itself is named
nomirompus which translates from spanish
into do not break me meanwhile if you
visit the site again after you've solved
the riddles and received the first image
you'll also get another image of a
message in the riddler's code can you
solve it there could be even more on the
site to discover over the coming days
and weeks which might either lead to
additional material related to the
batman or something that hints at the
riddler's future please do not lie
what is the price for your blind eye
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you